Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to Vee is Calling.
Now this is a type of... not quite simulator game, but you're a person who's going
on a video date, and things aren't what they seem.
What's my first name?
Markipoo!
Hi! "Call accepted."
Hello. "Hello, Vee?"
It sure is, Vee!
And how in...i-in the world would this be more fun than dinner?
If you don't mind me asking.
*laughs* "Really?"
I somehow doubt that VERY much.
Uhh - [mumbled] I could save...nah.
Again! I have my doubts!
*laughs* And I'm not a hundred percent sure about that.
Woah, it's a little early to be talking about love!
We're on our barely first date over here!
"That makes sense" *laughs* That makes sense. Sure it does!
I am go with that!
Wow, I'm desperate. *laughs*
Oh you know!
Four foot nine, super manly!
Let's see.
Yeah, I wanna know about you, and your needs.
Yeah? Well I'm more curious.
Oh that was me! Never mind, sorry.
*laughs* Agoo, senpai!
*laughing* I don't really, I play the trumpet!
I just bought a red trumpet and it's delightful!
That seems the opposite of what I know!
Ooh, wait a minute.
Now I have bad memory, but I'm pretty sure maybe no.
Let's see.
Whoops! Woah what did I do?
Uh, oh, it's, is this the save screen?
Oh, w-okay I just saved. Alright.
*gruff voice* Because I'm actually a robot.
Because she's a computer...
She's a "computer scientist!"
Uh-oh.
What was that?
Oh no, oh shit. *laughs* Oh fudge!
Oh I didn't notice!
Something up here maybe?
Oh.
I have a funny feeling that *you* might know what's happening.
Yeah that happens!
Op, welp, *laughs* that- there goes more!
And don't grin at me all smug-like!
Aw crap. *laughs* Oh no.
What was that?
Oh boy.
"What was that?"
That's what I said.
Oh no.
*laughs* Oh, this got sinister, holy shit!
Oh, oh my god!
Hello! Hi lady! Wow, that's creepy!
Oh!
Uhh...?
Huh?!
*laughs* W-what?
Oh, okay!
What?!
What is my first name? Markifart!
What the fuck happened??
Oh, hello Vee! Okay, hang on.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna go forward a bit.
Okay, "well today at work..."
*Aroused voice* Sexy! Erotic!!
Wait a minute! This is weird!
Okay, so this is what I said before...
Okay, so I saved...
Because she's a computer...
Uh-oh.
*laughs* Hey! Is it just leading down the same path?
Uh-oh!
Alright, let's save again here.
Let's see, uh... "I'm telling you, it's gone!"
What the hell is happening?
*laughs* Ohh. Oh no.
Let's see.
"Freaking out, you don't seem to care?"
Awwwhhh! More files!
I care about us!
Oh!! She's admitting it! That's different!!
Oh no!
Oh, she put everything back...
Aww.
"End." END?
OH THAT'S THE END?! YOU'RE JUST GONNA END IT?!
Wait! There was one more op- like-
There was one option where I was kind of accusatory towards her - could I like...?
Could that change anything?
Let's see, "do you know what's happening?" No-
*mumbling* Let's see, "take over your computer..."
No. She just goes.
I think - Aw man, is there only two endings?
There might be, I have no idea! Okay, wow, that was a short-
THAT WAS SO COOL THOUGH!
I was into it! It was so creepy! All of the sudden in the other option, like, wow *laughs* that went creepy fast!
But I liked that!
I wonder if there are really only two options? If there are... man.
I- I don't see how, any other way for them to go because towards the end there it just seemed like there were two different routes but...
There's probably some internal flags on like, how nice you are in being on the actual date and all that.
But either way!
This was really cool! This was made for a game jam as well, I believe, but I'm not 100% sure.
But it's a really good idea, and I like it a lot, so-
Thank you everybody so much for watching! Let me know what you thought of this in the comments below.
I'd love to hear your input on it, and maybe, maybe this developer will make more stuff like this in the future.
This might even be the same person that made the like, "One Night Stand Simulator"? It kinda seems similar to that.
But probably not, probably not at all. But either way-
Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you, in the next video, buh-bye!
(Upper Mark): Huh. *laughing* That seems like a very morally bad thing to do!
(Lower Mark): There we go, got it. *Screams* WHAT THE FUCKING FUCK?!